le race dakar pas de changement au
classement général l'italien meo nie
toujours en tête côté moto le japonais
matsuoka toujours premier côté voitures
mais l'image qu'on gardera sans doute de
cette édition c'est celle de johnny
premier rallye pour le chanteur une
épreuve dans tous les sens du terme
à trois jours de l'arrivée le meilleur
de la course de johnny récit christophe
duchiron pierre lepetit le plus facile
ce serait d'en rire parce que j'ai n'y
est arrivé ce matin à l'heure où
d'ordinaire on fait la fermeture des
boîtes de nuit à saint tropez ou à paris
bref c'était pas la joie
morceaux choisis on a tous je me suis
foulé le poignet dans les dunes du chai
le bol le volant c'est que tu veux on a
caché encore un truc leur sort à droite
bus tout à eau
la commencer la foire et ont retrouvé
tenu la route
je promets que vous l'aurez compris on
peut être un noctambule et passé une
mauvaise nuit
johnny hallyday rené metge ont perdu 8
heures sur le vainqueur de l'étape
c'est beaucoup mais c'est sans doute le
prix à payer pour celui qui ne veut pas
se priver de désert oui évidemment le
plus facile ce serait d'en rire parce
que sur le sable show johnny hallyday
n'est pas lawrence d'arabie
mais un simple amateur quand on était
bien un amateur oui comme le sont les
bouchers charcutiers boulangers employés
acteurs chanteurs ou princesse qui ont
fait eux aussi depuis des années la
popularité du dakar bien sûr le plus
facile serait d'en rire car chaque jour
qui passe est une épreuve mais
qu'importe
entre un bon coup de volant une réplique
bien senti johnny reste johnny tu te
rends sur les pas perdus leur coeur
on serait là depuis le vainqueur tous
nos voeux accompagnent johnny hallyday
rené metge pour rallier dakar
même si sans conteste l'idole des jeunes
n'est pas encore le prince du désert